[Music]
[Music]
you ready Femina continent jackal I'll
be waiting
dad sorry what was that last thing you
said wait that last part they didn't
catch it well is anything when you mean
I didn't well I said I'll be waiting and
then I stopped talking
dad no Lloyd that's right your son and
it's Lloyd no ll o yd I named you you've
ruined my life that's not true I haven't
even been a part of your life how could
I ruin it wasn't even there baby now we
got bad
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm kicking ass animals to form the
secret ninja force
are you ready to risk your life but
Ninjago yes I am on you
maybe I know you want me to save myself
so
[Music]
hello who is this Lloyd Garmadon your
son hmm
[Music]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect I mean my mom is weird
and collect seashells your dad level
cities and attacks innocent people so
they've all got that quarks you know I
knew I had a big with this movie time to
get down and dirty ninja style the cast
of this is bananas I mean it's really
like the most talented funniest people
you're gonna be fine let me text your
mother Lloyd is you know he's a
complicated guy who has a father who's
an evil warlord
no no it's Lloyd dad he's been living in
his shadow his whole life at his heart
he's a great friend and he's a great
leader I believe in each of you Lord
Garmadon is he's narcissistic bad guy
who is always trying to sort of rule
over Ninjago when I cry which I said can
do I weep tears of fire hit
guys supposed to be that the hothead
he's a fire Zane is the robot who has
applications to being a real live team
birthday hug let me get in on that all
increase the pressure dramatically I
play J and he is the blue ninja
electricity he wants to be cool
but he really can't be nobody's parents
are perfect
my mom is weird and collects seashell
your dad level cities and attacks
innocent people so they've all got that
corks Mia is the only girl in the ninja
game
she's fiercely independent she is not
some sidekick in the game she's a really
powerful part of it
my character Cole is more laid-back than
the other ninjas yeah watch this but
master Wu is the founder of the secret
India for know in the teachers students
how to become perfect ninja Coco's roids
mom and she's very sweet she just tried
to be a big beacon of positivity and
light for him oh and also don't forget
if your dad attacked the city again
today just be sure to duck and give the
all-clear it was kind of intimidating
because it literally was like The Improv
Olympics ten for ten forty with the ten
for ten forty one I have no idea what
you're saying to me right now just a
pile of words falling right out of your
mouth how did you go that everyone and
recording with all the other cast
members is really really exciting cuz
you could just kind of play around and
see what would happen you know how did
you gain two arms I was bit by snake no
yes but it's Nev arms exactly do you
mean like a spider oh no I was bit by a
snake yeah then the snake had been
bitten by a spider and then the snake
bit me so that's why are you guys
actually buying any of this how else
would you explain in the Lord you
weren't there
voicing a character and
is much more freewheeling and it creates
a kind of fun there Lloyd's on his own
journey to sort of find himself but like
all good teams you have to operate
within a group throughout the story they
realized that it is about believing in
yourself and just finding that inner
peace and peace has felt ti ECE which I
do think is one of the greatest funds of
all time the fate of Angelo is in your
hands are you ready yes I am yeah maybe
let's do this when they asked me to do
stunts for the lego ninjago movie I
thought I had to use Lego and then I
realized oh I can do a stunt like a
live-action martial art movie that makes
more sense in the movie I play master Wu
so I'm the teacher of my stunt team and
the Ninjago team I'm very proud of the
Jackie Chan stand here they are the best
of the best so the students in India
should be the best maybe we never work
on a movie like this before it was
interesting to make real-life action
into animation my favorite fight of the
movie is between me and Garmadon is a
very important moment I wanted action
design to be very special
now I'm gonna fight you
[Music]
everything the stunting does the ninjas
do also
there goes pinky these are confirmation
I have been doing a stunt more than
fifty years I've never done anything
like this before
trust me this ninjas and really fight I
think you will be very impressed
[Music]
you ready for me to conquer Ninjago okay
[Music]
hey ninjas it's me Nia and it's
back-to-school time so I'm gonna show
you everything you need in your locker
to be ninja and nail the school year
anyone can be ninja if you feel strong
confident and powerful here's the ninjas
guide to everything a ninja needs to be
a ninja first I like to have photos of
all my heroes who inspire me next you
need a ninja mask to protect your secret
identity
nobody knows mine except for kya kool
Jay zane lloyd and you his robots I've
also got sushi for lunch
my lucky chopsticks oh and here's
something every ninja needs in her
locker makeup to camouflage force
definitions
[Music]
see perfectly camouflage so ninja looks
like I gotta go take care of this so if
you do happen to be a real ninja the
last thing your locker needs secret
passageway leading to a warehouse space
filled with blood kicking necks have a
great school year
the lego ninjago movie ready PG tonight
what are you do to my super secret
volcano office fathers were dad we're
gonna beat in San Diego and I thought I
could conquer it excellent warlord
instinct son general number one bring me
my conquering flags to plant on this San
Diego oh come I con no no more flags we
could do some father-son sightseeing oh
oh happy fun to conquer no don't oh that
- that's not my gosh la la can you
imagine how beautiful this city would
look at him smashed by my giant mech
please just stop no I'm totally gonna
conquer this place it's at the top of my
bucket list
don't worry he is not going to destroy
San Diego yet today but someday
hey mom can we talk about dad
dorba dog so when you guys got together
was dad always an evil okay well here it
is I got sucked up we have so many plans
who swim bishop's he said he wanted to
conquer the world I thought it was a
figure of speech but if I had never met
Garmadon I would have never had you
Hey
[Music]
costas beer students are tuning your
nose and when to fight and when you play
in the shadows
unbelievable
[Music]
dad Lloyd that's right and it's Lloyd
dad it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect yeah but I feel like there's
more to Garmadon that I need to know to
understand your future you must go back
to your ninja roots
your dad was a ninja - Lloyd you hear
that we don't waken the unstoppable
beast
the Alfa are you ready to risk your life
for Ninjago ninja
I haven't felt this good in a long time
no Lloyd are you okay yeah yeah I think
I think there's my arm is a bad look a
scale of 1 to 10 to help out is it oh
I'd say it's about a 7-point
arm ripped off this film is not yet
rated
[Music]